i i
i think a lot of the uh the
psychiatrists and the american
psychologists association these days
they view men and women as
biologically the same in our in our
minds and they don't
differentiate between the two well the
apa by default
treats treats males as toxically
masculine that's what they're teaching
these psychiatrists
and so they expect men and women to
be the same whatever blank slateism so
like
they ignore all the science between like
the neurological differences between men
and women that the
brain shape between men and women the
hormone levels and how they
uh affect our body and our emotions you
can take if you've ever talked to a girl
who did
uh like power lifting or bodybuilding
and they
took steroids if they took testosterone
like they'll tell you about
their emotional and moods changing and
becoming more masculine
you know it's not just a physical change
like those those hormones
make them emote differently to the same
stimuli
um we got one here as a follow-up says
how does one
recuperate from being surrounded by too
much feminine energy since childhood
by not having a strong alpha father
figure one of the things guys and i keep
telling you i'ma tell you again pick up
heavy [ __ ] put it down one and two
join a dojo learn how to be lethal learn
how to kick somebody's ass get your ass
kicked
you know you hang around places like
that you're gonna run run across
strong virtuous alpha men spend time
with them
you know do [ __ ] with them go out and
shoot guns uh hun i don't care like just
do man [ __ ]
stuff that you like right build
something
what do you got there this is a tweet
from the apa
back in i believe isn't yeah the 18th or
excuse me 2018
female grad students in psychology
outnumber males by approximately three
to one and have done so for more than a
decade
that's what you're getting into john
it's a feminize this is
why it is it is the school it is the
religion
psychology today especially the apa
anything that's an officially
feminism all it is is promoting so when
you get into marriage counseling when
you get to
there's it's no surprise it's no shock
that you know that everything's like
equal
even steven egalitarianism uh blank
slate
equality yeah like i think i've brought
it up before but i had a half hour
debate with
our group counselor whatever about the
differences between
men and women biologically and he's like
no there's a difference between you and
your wife
not between men and women it was i was
like
i was i was looking things up like i was
wondering if i could sue the guy
because i get that seems like that seems
like a
medical malpractice to me because you're
supposed to be a psychologist that helps
people out right
and you're telling them things that are
biologically incorrect and that's only
going to make somebody
more mentally uh through more mental
like
suffering you have to make this person
more crazy you're going to hurt them
i think it's probably one of the reasons
why we have so many like transgender
people right now too is because
they're not telling people the truth
about biology they're just letting them
go along with their [ __ ]
their craziness because they profit off
of it yes the more the more crazy they
are the more crazy people they deal with
the more drugs they can pump full of
people
the more they're going to keep coming
back to them and they just keep making
more money
most of these guys that go through this
this like process of changing
genders end up regretting it and they
end up committing suicide at the end of
it
yeah there's lots of data on that how
many societies how many how many psych
how many ideologies how many businesses
are dependent on the blank slate being
true
all of them almost that's that's why you
can't fare it out
they want you on the reservation man
they want you plugged into the [ __ ]
yeah you kick out the you kick out the
legs of uh what a
blank slate and you kick out the legs of
social constructionism and
everything crashes down falls apart
you